Hello little peanuts and porcupines
coffee on a Tuesday and Vlog 55.
Okay.
I love superheroes and I love good
movies.
Put those two things together and I go
fucking bananas.
One of my favorite superhero movies is
of course Sam Raimi,
amy's original spider man.
Not only because it's brilliant
storytelling and it is,
but because that movie really conveys
the grace,
the almost balletic movement of our hero
through the New York City skyline.
What gives spiderman his agility is a
combination of heightened reflexes and a
pre-cognitive spider sense.
After that,
super strengthened some handy webs and
you have the best time.
This side of Superman.
Indeed.
I've spent countless hours walking
through city staring wistfully up at
buildings as the other me.
The Spiderman may swings here and there
and deep parabolic arcs twisting into
triple flips,
landing.
I don't know on the poll,
some American flag atop the empire state
building.
Okay.
I lost myself there a little bit though.
I've been known to loiter around the
spider exhibit at the Natural History
Museum.
It's a real human tragedy that we don't
get to have super powers.
I mean,
the best we can do is free running and
by we I of course mean other people and
yet there are times when walking through
the densely populated spaces of
Manhattan that I've marveled at my
ability to move through a crowd and not
crash into every other person.
Sometimes I can actually feel myself
perceiving the speed and crisscrossing
directionality of all the people in
front of me and when I get to the other
side,
I feel like a regular Han Solo.
What is that?
Why aren't we a mess in airports or on
street corners?
How are we all avoiding one another when
we look out onto a moving crowd,
but we're actually seeing beyond busy
people talking on their cell phones is
subtle increases and decreases in the
intensity of light reflecting off
objects when light intensity increases
and object is moving towards you.
Usually when it decreases,
it's moving farther away,
but the retina is also sensing
directionality.
Neurons fire and in code as they sense
edges moving over backgrounds in time,
and we have separate groups of neurons
dedicated to perceiving things moving
left or right or clockwise or
counterclockwise.
Perceive your own sense of
directionality and action.
Fix Your eyes on the center of this
animation.
What I'm about to show you is what's
called the waterfall,
illusion or motion after effect.
Stare at a waterfall for long enough and
the neuron group coding it's downward
motion,
will,
for lack of a better term,
get bored and adapt to make that the
norm.
Turn your head away to say a stationary
rock and the rock will seem to move
upward in the opposite direction of the
false.
That's because the stationary thing
relative to the adapted normal is
actually up or instead of circles moving
inward,
this pattern may look like it's moving
outward.
Add to this,
our eyes on average,
separated by six centimeters are
remarkably accurate at triangulating and
object as long as it's within 100
meters.
If it's beyond 100 meters,
we have to rely on other tricks like
perspective or motion parallax taking
all this information,
the brain can calculate the velocity of
a variety of moving things at once.
The Retina,
which we should never forget,
is the only visible part of the brain
carries information via the optic nerve.
To the lateral geniculate nucleus and
into the visual cortex in the occipital
lobe of the brain.
From here,
the data splinters down two paths.
The two stream hypothesis made famous by
David Milner and Melvin goodale in the
early nineties,
holds that some information goes down
the ventral stream to the temporal lobe
for object identification and
recognition so that we can figure out
what it is that we're looking at.
The rest goes down the dorsal stream to
the parietal lobe where we process the
objects spacial location relative to the
viewer.
In other words,
there's two streams,
one for what and one for where what was
merely color edge and brightness in the
occipital lobe is a map spatial
awareness.
By the time it reaches the parietal now
our knowledge of how we process movement
is only as good as our working knowledge
of the brain of grass,
which is to say the least incomplete,
better and find our technologies will
give way to a better and finer
understanding of the brain.
But really understanding the brain is
only a function of our desire to
understand in order to treat certain
kinds of brain damage.
What's incredible is that when
functioning normally,
we don't have to think about each and
every complicated step from perception
to cognition to actually we can like
certain heroic walk crawlers,
navigate our environment with a natural
grace in a kind of balletic dance with
the fast and chaotic movement of
everything else.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
That was spider sense.
Whatever life holds in store for me,
I will never forget these words with
great power comes great responsibility.
This is my gift,
my curse.
Who am I?
I'm Spiderman.
Uh.